[Music]
i did think you were dead until i got
your call you know
he's been gone for weeks not a single
word very unlike him
i'm introducing myself it's etta candy
i'm steve trevor's
secretary what is the secretary no well
i do everything i
go where he tells me to go and i do what
he tells me to do well where i'm from
that's called slavery
i really like her fantastic ladies after
you do i
like his name is stephen
i have sworn to return him to his people
and i intend to go with him
if you wish to steal from the amazons
you will have to go through their
protector
is that what you want no
it's what you taught me so be it
his arrival is a sign
man's world needs our help man's world
is past him
that is not your choice to make
if you leave you will never become queen
you will never set foot on this island
again are you truly willing to throw
away
everything you are for the mere chance
of helping them
ask me again mother
[Music]
it's strange that you should be my own
daughter
and yet someone i do not recognize
anymore
as if you could outdrink an amazon you
pathetic lightweight
ah crap oh yes i knew exactly what you
were trying to do and please don't use
that language around me
evening folks sorry to bother you but
we're collecting stupidity fines
and well bringing a date into a
neighborhood this dangerous
this late pretty freaking stupid
is this man robbing us steve here
there's a gift certificate to the blue
crab in there too
enjoy give him nothing
the wallet no we're going to hold on to
that
but there is something i want from you
an apology
for contributing to my present
disillusionment with men in general
can you believe this crazy chick i'm not
gonna ask again
the wallet diana he's got a gun
someone could get hurt maybe i want
someone to get hurt
[Music]
ah
well i'm sorry
apology accepted look it's wonder woman
[Music]
what is it like working with superman
when you fought the aliens
were you scared um are you really from
an island with no men
i may i have this dance yes
[Music]
thank you mister wayne bruce wayne
i appreciate the rescue i'm surprised to
see you here
from what i've heard this isn't really
your sort of affair i've decided to get
out more
have a little fun
[Music]
stay back you can't approach without my
permission permission yes do what we say
and you won't be harmed
i have the princess clear
excuse me
oh is this popular yes although my
admirers are usually unarmed
[Music]
what happened with the princess forget
it we've got to get out of here before
wonder woman
you give up right
i will not look at
me i
perfused
at me
are you a fool you can't poison me with
my own venom
perhaps but that is not what i was
[Music]
planning
[Music]
no look at me as
you wish
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
submit do you miss it
you're home a bit
but i came here to make your world a
better place
and once your mother teaches me more
about your culture
that's what i'll do can you just
decide that to make the whole world
better
everyone gets to decide what they want
to do with their life
i might not succeed but this is what i
choose to try
but not everyone has to choose the same
thing
what about you vanessa what will you
dedicate your life to
i don't know killing teenage vampires
don't worry vampires aren't real
i wasn't worried and they are
so what so we do nothing no we do we are
doing something we are we just
we can't save everyone in this war this
is not what we came here to do
[Music]
no but it's what i'm going to do
diana
[Music]
[Music]
thank god
she's taking all the fire let's go
ah
hello
cheeseburger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
come on go
[Music]